tiendas llenas de productos navideños
pero sin compradores es una temporada de
Navidad marcada por la profunda crisis
económica en Líbano que afectado el
poder adquisitivo de la población y su
ánimo que me las decoraciones navideñas
en logrado levantar
el año más duro en comparación con
anteriores porque la gente no tiene
dinero y la diferencia entre la
cotización del dólar estadounidense y la
libra libanesa es demasiado alta
obligados a abrir hasta las 22:11 ahora
no hay nada
como una de las peores crisis de la
historia moderna por el Banco Mundial el
colapso económico en Líbano iniciado en
2019 llevo la moneda local a perder el
90% de su valor frente al dólar la
pandemia y la explosión del puerto de
Beirut en agosto de 2020 agravaron el
panorama ahora a según la ONU cuatro de
cada cinco libaneses se consideran
pobres de acuerdo con el umbral de
ingresos de 2 $ al día esto sumado una
crisis política que dejó al país sin
gobierno durante más de un año ahora son
muchas las familias que no saben cuándo
volverán a ver brillar su árbol de
Navidad